me how are you I'm good how are you said
I'm happy to be talking to ministers you
look stunning
and you're presenting tonight yes I am
I'm presenting with Salma Hayek and it's
really fun and exciting she's gorgeous
she's got gorgeous big breasts if you
see in a hearse and she's just rockin
I'm like is that body of hers incredible
that's wonderful and funny it's so funny
it's so much fun to be around
I just wanted to say like do a great
presenting job right and have fun oh I
will that's the mission I'm not wearing
these Jimmy Choos for nothing okay
I'm wearing them to have some fun
they're doing good right now they do it
they I have put some little CBD oil on
them so they're doing good second person
that has said that tonight that's in car
yeah yeah you know the powers of natural
medicine I just drink it you put it on
your feet yeah I put it on my feet yeah
yeah cause it'll sort it'll absorb you
know every single nerve in your body is
in your feet so every organ everything's
connected to your feet so to come up
yeah now that would help too
this is for a good cause okay Joey is
doing you toast you sit and then you say
what charity and I wanna support and
moiwa send a thousand dollars okay great
great great great yes
yeah I got one yes success and
prosperity Thank You moet for donating
to the she ready foundation we gonna get
these foster kids suitcases and the
children and a probation department we
taking care of all these kids she ready
[Music]